I want to talk about alternative
solutions to taking pills for the rest
of your life. If you struggle with
speaking anxiety at all, you've probably
encountered beta blockers such as
propanol is pills you take that reduce
your heart rate, reduce your blood
pressure, reduce the bodily symptoms you
experience. A lot of people are looking
to that as a solution to their speaking
anxiety. I'm Tristan de Monttoello. I
was one of the fastest competitors to
reach the final of the world
championships of public speaking. And
that journey completely changed my life.
It changed my confidence. It changed how
I walked around in the world. And it led
me to co-found the company
ultraeaking.com with Michael Gendler
where we've devoted our lives to
figuring out how to solve public
speaking anxiety once and for all. So,
let me start by saying that I have
nothing particularly strong against
propanol. I don't really like the idea
of taking pills for the rest of my life
in anything. But I know plenty of
students who take propanolal have taken
propanol. But I know many many more who
have gotten off of these pills and no
longer imagine a world where they'd ever
need them because of the journey they've
been on tackling their speaking anxiety.
The way I see propanal, I see it as a
life jacket. If you're thrown in the
middle of the ocean and you don't know
how to swim, a life jacket will save
your life. But the reality is, if you
are completely dependent on this life
jacket and you live in water world, then
it's probably a good idea to learn how
to swim. In my mind, communication is
ubiquitous. It's everywhere in your
life, particularly the type of
communication that you can't prepare
for. So, what can you do to reduce your
anxiety? There are three things I want
to state. Number one is you want to
change the state in which your body is
when you find yourself in a situation
where you know you're going to speak. If
you have anxiety, you're experiencing a
lot in your body. Your body is going to
be on high alert. So before going to
work, before a social situation, before
a presentation, go out for a long run,
go out for a bike ride, a swim, a
workout. Do anything that's going to
release endorphins and allow your body
to have a lower baseline. Second piece
of advice is take a breath before you
speak. It sounds so simple, but if you
just take one breath in and a long
breath
out, which looks completely natural,
you're going to lower your baseline,
which is going to lower the peak of
anxiety, which is going to make you feel
that much more comfortable. And last but
not least, maybe the most important
piece of advice I can give you is join
some kind of a club that's going to
create a safe environment for you to
practice your skills. You can join a
bowling club, a gardening club, a
professional club. It doesn't matter.
You can even join an ultraeaking club
which is specialized in speaking
anxiety. The only thing that matters is
that you find yourself in a situation in
a scenario where you're going to be with
the same people week after week. Because
what's going to happen, you're going to
get comfortable with these people.
You're they're all going to be rooting
for you as a human being. And as a
result, you're going to be able to take
more and more risks to show yourself
more and more. And as you do so in an
environment that's very safe, where
you're going to be rewarded for taking
risks, your body is going to learn that
it's actually safe in doing so. And
you're going to have a playground where
you can spend time finding yourself and
finding your own voice. What you're
doing is you're building a stack of
evidence that's builds up your
confidence and is going to allow you to
then go into different environments
knowing what it feels like to be you.
what it feels like to be a confident
version of you. Look, there's no shame
in taking medication for real
problems. But for the vast majority of
people, there's a world in which you can
take the life jacket off and learn how
to swim. I know this can be very scary.
It's a big journey, but it's a very
personal journey. It will be very unique
to you, but it's going to be very
energizing and rewarding as you're on
the journey. And I think that's what's
magnificent about these personal growth
ventures that we get on. As we take the
first step, we get energy from that very
thing. So this is a truly worthwhile
journey and I wish you good luck.